see we've seen a variety of references
so far in these sessions to various
agents that God uses to accomplish the
divine purpose chapter 6 already is
talking about God on the search for a
messenger to deliver the word of
judgment to Jerusalem we've got
references to an individual servant
we've got references so far to a group
of people at the beginning of chapter 34
one of the more interesting ideas about
the servant figure is Jerusalem itself
that is apparently serving as the
servant when we get to chapter 41 the
word servant begins to appear more
regularly in the text in the second
Isaiah that seems to be the preferred
way of talking about these agents of
various sorts and furthermore Israel
itself is explicitly identified as the
servant in chapter 41 what you make of
the way that Isaiah understands this
image of Israel as the servant how does
that work is that the same thing as the
beginning of chapter 41 or is this
something yet different yeah well when
you have this god of other nests this
god of holiness towering above the
cosmos the question becomes how is God
involved if God is so transcendent and
there's this plethora of agents agents
of judgment Assyria the Empire of
Babylonia but there seems to be another
type of instrument that's a little
different and that's where this language
of servant or in Hebrew evett comes in
as you say in chapter 41 verse 8 Israel
is called my servant Jacob whom I've
chosen descendant of Abraham my friend
the servant is special kind of
instrument in might in my opinion they
are confidence of God there in on the
plan they should know they've seen what
God's Word can do to history how it
cannot be
normal ways of thinking and operating so
they're in a special position to work
with God or to manifest God's plan and
purposes this is referenced it to
Abraham is significant Abraham and Sarah
you remember were these frail aged folks
who couldn't have children infertile
barren they were exiles from their
homeland but God worked God's Word
through these frail mortal finite people
and a miracle of new life they had a
pregnancy they had a child when God in
verse 10 here says I am your god it's a
direct quote of the promise to Abraham
back in Genesis 17 7 so this is a
special brand of servant I think well
you think that this is in fact the
remnant that Isaiah has been talking
about we've already talked about the way
in which one gets to be a part of the
remnant and you're not going to be much
after you have gone through the kind of
judgment then the remnant went through
well oh is this the exotic community
that is beaten down by the Exile thank
God would like the community to look to
Abraham and Sarah and to take up this
lifestyle the question is will they or
will they find this prophecy unrealistic
it's fine for professors to talk about
this concept but how does it work in
real life I think that's a question of
relevance for day-to-day living that is
very much pressing ok so the community
itself is apparently being given a job
here it may not feel that it is up to it
and because of that they very much
resemble the notion of later communities
of faith that our find themselves in the
same situation of identifying with this
they know also what God's plan is
because they are the ones who were
reading this Lee said now what they are
the interpreters of this tradition and I
supposed to understand where they are in
the tradition and they are the ones
being addressed to do these things it is
the is really
knows God's plan or should know God's
plan and they're the ones who are to be
the agents but whether they are actually
up to this task is a an ongoing question
they feel they're not was the commute
they feel they're not they feel like
this worm in verse 14 right on justice
this worm Jacob that's going to be
transformed miraculously into God's
agent of judgment on someone else it is
counterintuitive but we've already heard
what God has to say in chapter 40 about
people who think they are not up to the
job and the bottom line is it doesn't
seem too much matter whether they think
they're up to the job or not they've
still got to perform in this way it's
part of this divine plan and there is no
way that that plan is going to be
thwarted well if if God's transcendence
is indeed the flip side of a vaio nning
up to one's frailty I mean maybe there
is kind of a magic spirituality to this
that if you can embrace your position as
our worm maybe there's some spiritual
power and that that can be tapped into
so do you think then the idea is that
God is going to give special support and
power to people who are inherently weak
but nevertheless agreed to take on the
the job this is what it sounds like at
the beginning of chapter 42 where the
image is changed we're no longer talking
now about a group we're talking again
about an individual yeah this is the
first of the servant songs where this
mysterious figure of a head or a servant
is encapsulated in this individual
dramatic player so now it's a specific
individual again again this great
variety of agents and servants and so on
that seem to be involved in this and
whatever else Isaiah wants us to do with
this apparently we're not meant to
reduce this to one particular way of
thinking about it certainly the Book of
Isaiah does never nails down
things in a way that would allow us to
sort of reduce it or pigeonhole it or
anchor it like that what do you make
then of chapter 43 where the word
servant is not used you just made a
distinction between agents of one sort
or another that we have seen elsewhere
in Isaiah and suddenly in chapter 43 we
get people who are described as
witnesses and they're very strange
witnesses because it says they are blind
and yet have eyes and they're deaf and
yet have ears this again harks back to
chapter 6 of Isaiah this is why you
carry this judgment takes the form of
people who are having eyes but do not
see and they're not allowed to see they
have ears and they are not allowed to
hear and that's the kind of witness now
that is being referred to in chapter 43
is this the same thing as the servants
that are referred to later well the
folks are supposed to be the confidence
of God according to verse 9 the the
nations of the world pagan nations who
worship the idols can't have any insight
into God's plan can they proclaim the
former things are they in on how God's
Word is shaping history over the long
widescreen trajectory now the idols are
a force within creation there the
weighing the forces of nature fertility
death only the transcendent God knows
this plan and God's servants so they
Israel should have a particular role
they are in touch with God's singular
uniqueness I don't want us to lose track
of a special way that we meet God in
this material in verse 11 God declares
these great monotheistic statements I
even I am Yahweh there's no other
possible Savior I declare I save I
proclaim no one else can do it so on the
one hand in this poem then verse 9
you've got these ignorant nations that
just are not in on the plan at the end
of the poem you've got God who's just
singular incomparable other holy and
what do you have smack in the middle of
the poem in verse 10 but the call to
God's people to take up this role of
servant and to be witnesses to mediate
between God's other nests and the entire
globe so what's going on is not just for
some small selects chosen people of God
not just the children of Abraham but
you've really got a vision that's quite
universal and trying to reach out to all
the nations and peoples of the earth
Israel's called to be right there smack
in the middle of a holy God and people
spread worldwide that need to not to be
in touch with with God in spite of the
obvious fact that the people who are
being called to do this are not really
cut out for the job yeah which is
characteristic of most communities of
faith who see in this material a direct
Commission to them to be God's witnesses
well I think what's what's what's what
we'll have to look out for since they're
not cut out for this job is that why
these servant songs are focusing in on
this ideal individual for a time might
these this individual servant have to do
some of the work until the larger
community is ready to follow seeds so
the individual servant becomes a model
then for the entire community which
learns from it some kind of lesson that
it will then take and work out can he
get that energy behind this new growth
this new sprout from the dead stump can
it fertilize bear spread it spread seed
share the energy in such a way that a
whole community is formed